Rick is in Louisville Kentucky hi Rick
welcome to the Dave Ramsey show hey Dave
are you better than I deserve what's up
in your world well and I had a couple
questions get an IRS hang-up currently
going on right now just to give you the
basics real quick me and my fiance make
a gross combined income a year around
one hundred and five hundred and ten
I took my taxes a couple years taxi or
17 return 18 to a woman that I probably
shouldn't have and she done my taxes
pretty badly and as a result I now I
just did the amendment and now I owe the
IRS we're thinking at least somewhere
around 4,400 we're currently on baby
step two we've got the credit cards paid
off all I have left is about eighteen
thousand on a car and eighteen thousand
on a bike the only kind of stipulation
of this IRS thing is we don't really
know like we sent the amendment but we
don't really know when they're gonna
like send me back the quote-unquote love
letter to explain like you know how to
pay it when today it you know how much
interesting penalties if there is gonna
be any that kind of stuff and I kind of
was wondering we put do we put off
paying so even if you have a tax
professional help you with the amendment
yes a competent one yes
I'll be that one that one that deals and
chart drivers you know taxes and the
whole per diem paying all that yep okay
all right and you understand that with
your girlfriend there isn't a we under
the law there's a you and her
okay so you can't file married filing
jointly when you're not married so you
have a tax problem now which of these
debts are yours the car and the bike
technically yes yep not technically
they're yours I mean it's just great up
yeah if she goes away if she goes away
those that are loans sitting there
looking at you and what do you make I
make I gross about eighty seventy eight
day to get here
gross progress revenue on your trucking
or gross profit that you pay taxes on
well on the company driver okay so how
did you get behind on your taxes well
okay so taxi or 2017
I had my ex living with me and her two
kids until I cleaned three all year Oh
drunk our okay all right so you're an
employee and you make what you make you
make eighty seven eight okay and in the
proper amount of taxes proper amount and
you owe eighteen on a bike and eighteen
on a car $36,000 okay either all right
well I can tell you when your IRS bill
is due now as soon as you mailed it it's
supposed to have a check with it and the
tax preparer could properly calculate
that there may be some adjustments on
interest or penalties later but you need
forty four hundred dollars yesterday so
you have three debts forty four hundred
plus penalties to the IRS 18 and 18 am I
missing something
no give you money yeah we we don't have
any money dude there is no way I have
about I'm sorry I have about three
thousand and savings okay that I'm
currently taking about twelve every week
good okay well the first thing I do is
get ready for the IRS you need a war
chest so you need five grand in savings
let's call it six grand in savings that
because of your plate what we call your
baby step ones a thousand dollars as a
starter emergency fund and you're going
to need forty four hundred plus
penalties so I'm going to call that five
grand plus one is six grand so your
first goal number one is roll up your
sleeves and beans and rice rice and
beans no life get on a tight budget and
quickly turn that three
the 6002 get ready and as soon as that
IRS love letter comes you write them a
check that day and you send it back and
you don't think anything else about it
you put it behind you okay that's thing
one okay the thing to is you got too
much money tied up in things that go
down in value with motors and wheels
mm-hmm yeah even though it's right at or
less than half of my yearly income it's
all debt though yeah so if you can be a
hundred percent debt free in in two
years starting from today and you want
to keep both of them that's fine thank
you November of this year maybe December
okay all right so you really are on
beans and rice then yeah okay
all right then can keep them both but
you're pretty heavily invested in things
that sit in your garage while you drive
a truck right yep okay yep I know that
you know she's well now me with this do
so it's as far as that you know you know
you know kind of got on the same page
with that even though technically my dad
strongly I strongly recommend that she
not do that unless you put a ring on her
finger I have so when are you getting
married we're thinking some time in jail
okay well then she can go your debts
okay cuz she'll be yours and you'll be
herbs and all that from the laws
standpoint the spiritual standpoint and
all that yeah good okay cool then that
that's gonna be the way to go about it
it but but don't mix your money with
your roommate until you are married
because you will find out what the law
says about roommates is different than
what the law says about wives and with
the Texas say about that and so just a
bad plan all the way around so good good
we're cleaning this up by December
you're gonna be a completely different
man debt-free and married Wow and no IRS
chasing you your life's gonna Merry
Christmas
yeah this is gonna be great things are
changing for you in a good way brother
I'm glad to hear it
thanks for calling in